hi I'm Marcia I'm from Poland I just saw
him directly to meet Gary it's pretty
cool
thank you make questions I'm
entrepreneur it's very great but not all
days are great in a company so what are
your tips and tricks for tough days
I think there's massive confusion around
entrepreneurship entrepreneurship sucks
I mean it's lonely it's high-risk I mean
I can't live without it but it's like a
bad boyfriend right a girlfriend right
like like it's there's a ton of bad days
being an entrepreneur not to mention 98%
of entrepreneurial ventures are gonna
fail so there's gonna be a really bad
[ __ ] day in your future you know
hopefully not for you or any of you you
know for me I don't you know I think
this is a very personal question I think
it's how you're wired I'm so all-in
entrepreneur I prefer the pain I think
one of the reasons I love the Jets so
much is because they bring me so much
pain you know I I love the climb to me
the setback is exciting I love when
something goes wrong it's where I shine
the most but that's not for everybody
right I mean it could be very difficult
and when you start affecting your life
and your loved ones and all the other
things it can get real nasty to me the
way I handle things even though the few
rare days when I really struggle I take
a real step back and make pretend that
somebody called me and told me that my
mother or daughter were killed and I
know that's very dark and I apologize
but it's really what I do I literally am
able to at my deepest most struggling
moment within business take a step back
and remind myself that I can make a
trillion dollars tomorrow on Bitcoin and
and if something bad happened to the
people I love the most that it would
mean nothing and it very consistently
rewires me very quickly
I just put business in perspective at
the end of the day you know it's it's
money for me it's not really money it's
my legacy so I get hurt by it a little
bit more but uh yeah I mean it's you
know I put in perspective it's money and
you know what up
I had a daughter even while I was
married up until when I had Mischa
four years ago I secretly wanted to lose
all my money I had this weird twisted
dark fantasy of losing everything just
to rise again like a phoenix and remind
you [ __ ]